[Musique]
Les cheveux roux
très courts
bégayent,
ce type ne devient pas une pop star
[Musique]
c'est tellement improbable que
tu doives travailler plus dur parce qu'il y aura
toujours quelqu'un qui
le voudra plus que toi J'ai des CD en
vente et ils  payer ma nourriture Le club
n'est pas le meilleur endroit où il faut
attendre qu'une personne soit
comme ça, c'est exact et pour moi, c'était
Jamal, l'homme qui a aidé à lancer la
carrière des plus grands noms de la musique,
puis les succès ont commencé à se
produire en premier  Je suis en train de signer un album
pour la première fois en Amérique pour la
première fois, un concert à guichets fermés, la
plus grande tournée de tous les temps, vendant
neuf millions de billets,
tout dans ma vie s'est
tellement amélioré quand Sherry s'y est lancée, je me
suis marié et  Je suis un père qui a deux
filles, nous avons atteint notre apogée et
elles sont allées à
Cherry's Health, c'était vraiment mauvais et
puis tout à coup, mon meilleur ami Jamal est mort,
vous sentez que vous voulez faire un
documentaire et j'y suis allé ouais et ça
devrait  sois moi en studio et nous
jouerons le concert,
ce n'est pas ce qu'est le documentaire
[Musique]
Je l'ai perdu, ça a pris le dessus sur ma vie
à chaque fois que quelque chose d'énorme se produit J'ai
tendance à écrire une chanson à ce sujet, chaque chanson
me rappelle que tu '  je suis parti
[Musique]
Je ne l'ai jamais vu pleurer sur scène juste
danser les yeux fermés il n'a pas
eu le temps de réfléchir et d'être en paix
avec ses pensées
J'ai l'impression qu'à chaque instant j'apprends
encore à danser avec mes yeux
la vie fermée est imprévisible,
les plans peuvent changer très rapidement
[Musique]
et puis les feux d'artifice et puis les baisers et
puis Disney